hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans la plaie
messenger et tu tapes le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger
[Musique]
tu es la seule qui maillent je te le dis
sans pas et reste cool pb sinon je te
dirai pas et pas tuer les seules images
j'ai fait les vis sans fin est resté
cool bébé sinon je te dirai bye bye
l'âge d'or du rap rock c'est le petit
marcel schrotter et d'ailleurs qui a
toutes les allures mlk et d'hélicos live
1 1 1 woods était invité par des
fauteuils il te plait on s'amuse et
viège dépôt bühler qui mettait des films
je ne voulais pas te réveiller c'est
tout arrête avec tes qu'est ce qu'on y
voit plutôt en quoi tu joues
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça
autour de bruit se sauvera de la carte
son mais
[Applaudissements]
par ses potes ne se gêne pas pour m
arrêter exploit jamais de tourner au
téléphone il fera ce n'était pas lui qui
m'a juste le dise en phase de poule la
seule puissance
[Musique]
de cette fois les montants en partie
c'est l'orgie à plat
tu prends tes clips t'éclater tu te
taille sa mère avait raison les smad au
hockey m'a pas de catena blanc dans
cette affaire qui le regret c'est vrai
que tu as vrai supplice l'arrière qui le
voudraient savak septembre est celui de
la voie d'autant plus que ses habitudes
ses invités tous les soirs j'ai compris
pourquoi tu affiche un mépris la famille
appréciera bois ou trois sets mais s'est
fait ce qu'il sait
se plaît elle à 30 images s
et
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]